All right, hello everyone. People are just jumping on here and we'll get the screen shared. Okay, I hope everybody is having a good Monday. I had a great weekend.
I had a good weekend except for our air conditioner went out. So it was very hot and hopefully it's getting fixed today because not escaping the heat can be miserable.
And I hope you guys all had a good weekend. All right, let's get going. So just a reminder of the weekly lineup of Zoom calls so we've added the Zoom call on Monday. So noon, central standard time, obviously with me.
And then Tuesdays. So if you have not had a binder review and you have your binder contents, you certainly can jump on to the Tuesday 11 a.m. central standard time, binder review call.
And then we have Wednesdays, Dr. Connor's typical Zoom call Wednesdays for PM. And then Thursdays. If you have not had your genetic review and you have received all of your genetic information that we have emailed you.
You can jump on to the Thursday genetic review.
And then again, just a reminder how to submit a question for these Zoom calls. So logging on to the membership page on every on the top bar of every page. There's the blue button submit a question.
Most of you are familiar with that because you have submitted your questions. But if you're new, that is how you do it. So you just click that brings up this box and you fill out your
Information and then you hit send and we'll get that.
And that's the preferred way to ask your question for the Zoom call just keeps everything in one location. So we have less digging to do and then we're more likely to not lose your question.
All right, so we have a few things to go through. So somebody from last Wednesday's Zoom call sent a little Zoom call question saying they couldn't log in to the Zoom call. So I apologize for that.
Typically, the first thing you need to do is make sure that you have the right time. So we are in the central standard time. So depending on where everyone is located. It might be a different time zone.
So first, make sure you have the right time. If you're logging in at an incorrect time, you're obviously not going to be able to get on the call because it's not happening.
And then I screen. I took a screenshot of this page here. So this is the Zoom call page that is in the membership site.
So the best way to just join the call is to log into the membership site, click on the tab that says for Zoom calls.
You can even once you've clicked on that tab, this is the URL.
You could even save this or bookmark this URL and then zoom so that when it's time for a Zoom call, you can click on that. You still will have to log in to the membership site, but it'll bring you right to the Zoom call page.
And then these buttons down here. So you can just click this button to join the Zoom call directly. So this one is for Dr. Conner's Wednesday Zoom call.
And this one is for the Monday Zoom call with me. So whichever one you're trying to get on to just click that button. It should link you and then you'll have access. So hopefully, I don't know why if there's quirky things with people's computer or internet or what the deal is.
There is a way to dial in to a Zoom call. So if you don't want to connect through the computer, and I don't know what that number is right now, but certainly I can get that up and posted.
If you email me, I can send it to you. So there is a way to just dial into the call, where you don't have to use the computer.
And you obviously then won't be able to see the screen, but you'll be able to hear the audio. So that is an option. Let me know if you need that phone number, and I can send it to you.
And then of course, always remember that there is a playback. So again, on the Zoom call page here, if you were to scroll down a little bit, you would have the playback, so the recording of the most recent Zoom call.
And then you have access to all of the previously recorded Zoom calls so you can go through those. And I do believe now that there is separate tabs. You can click on so a tab for all of Dr. Conner's Zoom calls. And then there is a tab for my Zoom calls. So
utilize that. That's the best way to jump on. All right. So question here. Detox RIF programs do these programs actually eliminate toxins or how does a person get detox using the right.
It seems like the toxins would recirculate, but I don't know much about the right. So with detoxing and using the right. So it kind of depends on what program you're running.
If you're using the bulb, there's a number of different detoxification programs for bulb use. And those are generally stimulating the organs of detoxification.
So so it's helping in a broad sense to stimulate those organs to optimize their function to better help you detox. There might be a specific program.
You know, specific for heavy metals or so it's maybe targeting the frequencies a little bit differently depending on what you're trying to detox, but in general, the bulb is stimulating those organs to help them work better and to help
Overall detox if you're using a foot bath. There's that same concept overall support might be some different frequencies that you can get through the foot bath for detoxing.
But there's also the drawing out of the toxins component that you get from the foot bath. So you're actually pulling toxins from the body. It's part of the reason why the water gets so murky.
So they operate similarly, but the foot bath has a little extra drawing out component. Now, certainly, as far as recirculation is concerned, if we're doing a bunch of detoxing, we do want to make sure
That we are supporting all phases of detox because otherwise you're right. Then we could recirculate these toxins that our body is working so hard to get packaged up to be excreted.
And so if you're constipated, that is an issue. You could be recycling toxins.
So Dr. Connor's book I did a little screenshot here of Dr. Connor's book the seven phases of detoxification walks you through kind of each stage. So making sure you're not constipated. So doing coffee animas or taking some supplements, magnesium to help with constipation because we need to be eliminating what your body is working hard to get rid of
Making sure you're drinking enough water. So you're staying hydrated. So you're eliminating through your urine as well.
Gut support. So making sure that you know, we're doing what we can to eat clean healthy whole food. So we're not disrupting the gut microbiome. We're not creating a leaky gut scenario.
You know, you can have binders binders help to pull toxins from the gut and eliminate them through waste. The sun's spectrum has the
The prebiotic fiber of the probiotic. So in general, we need to have some good gut support. We need to support the liver. We need to support the gallbladder.
You know, all of these functions are important. So Dr. Connor's book available for free download goes into a lot more detail on supporting all phases of detoxification. So when we are running the detox programs, we are able to fully eliminate them. So take a look at that
For more detail
All right, is chlorine dioxide something to consider. I was forwarded these articles on MMS. It can help with many diseases and pancreatic cancer is included.
It's actually good for everyone to take helps with uptake of more oxygen in the red blood cells. Also look up Jim Humble. He has all the research on his website about it.
Link is below you can buy the liquids on Amazon for under $40. Okay, so
One of the one of the things and the concerns with with anything really that is claiming to be a cure all is that
Nothing is a cure all and in this product this MMS or chlorine dioxide
If you do that Google search you do get a lot of claims stating that it is kind of this cure all and that it helps with so many different things. And we do just need to be careful when anything is claiming to be a cure all because
It's not necessarily true for everything. It might be great for something's not so great for others. And then there's there's risk, you know, if
Somebody takes too much
There there is concern. So ultimately we do not use
Chlorine dioxide. We don't recommend it
It's it certainly is something that is an oxidizing agent. So thinking about kind of the mechanism of action can be great for killing off pathogens biotoxin
You know lime
Certain bacteria fungus mold. So some of these biotoxins it might be good at
Killing because it is an oxidizing agent, but just like any oxidizing agent it can cause
Damage to healthy tissue if it's not
Used appropriately. So we always want to be cautious
Again, we don't use it in our protocols
Dr. Connors is just not convinced that it's, you know, a super great cure all for cancer
Again, maybe better for a biotoxin, but maybe not so great for cancer and
Potential side effects if it is not used correctly. So certainly everybody is entitled to do whatever they want
So, you know, certainly if this is something that you really feel compelled to do
You certainly can just be careful and you know, let us know if you are doing this. We're going to start on a on a protocol and
Just so we can document have it in the notes here and know that you're doing that
Okay next question. Could you please chat about EMF safety
Specifically the whole house EMF blocker versus the whole house harmonizer
If we have one of these do we still need the heatron cell phone sticker and or the harmonizer bracelet
Bob's bedroom has the modem home computer and the rifle laptop would the home EMF shield or the harmonizer
Protect him from these EMFs or what should he do? It's all confusing
To us as far as what products are really needed
Also, is there an EMF blocking paint to recommend? Okay, so EMF so tons of information on the website
About EMFs
So certainly I highlighted this little blog post here
Cancer and EMF so you certainly can visit that and and look at information
So yes EMFs are something that
We want to minimize exposure to
You know, they're pervasive in our you know modernized world. We've got our cell phones on us all the time
We've got a laptop, you know, we've got five G towers going up everywhere and so we're we're constantly exposed
So doing what we can to minimize exposure is very beneficial. There are studies that suggest EMF
Exposure can be linked to cancer
It absolutely increases mTOR so I'm just gonna go to this page. I'll go back to the question page, but so mTOR
So these are genetic pathways and mTOR
Is a pathway that signals for growth all of these things in yellow on the perimeter here are things that can
stimulate mTOR
EMFs cell towers are one of them. This is a genetic pathway that helps your body
regulate and
You know kind of get rid of these harmful exposure some people have variants here
So some people are more sensitive than others
But certainly with all of this exposure that we're getting can increase glucose and insulin
We know that that stimulates mTOR or growth cancer cells obviously use glucose
For for growth, so we don't want to be stimulating mTOR and all of these things that we're exposed to are
Constantly stimulating mTOR
So what we want to do is stimulate a topogy and
These things can't be going on at the same time mTOR and a topogy
So we want to promote a topogy that cellular repairing cleanup
So this is the phase that we want patients to be in you can support this by fasting
Resveratrol
Tumoric and other tumour suppressor genes by addressing
specific tumour suppressor genes that you might have
variants on
We can use those tools to help support a topogy. So that's just a quick blurb about
EMFs and and cancer and why you know, we we do need to address this because we are constantly being exposed
The differences between some of the EMF products
Anything that is for the body is obviously for something that is to help protect the body help protect the cells
So the harmonizer bracelet or any wearables are going to be different than like the
the EMF whole home
Blocker or the harmonizer. So we have available on our store a hard wired unit that you can
Attach to the electrical box. So it does require an electrician. So
Part of you know kind of navigating what is necessary is just well what what can you afford
And you know what you know, what is mo you know, do you have a sensitivity? Do you have high EMF readings in your home?
So those are things that can be tested
But as far as the whole house
The whole house unit again, so you're paying for an electrician to come out and then it isn't cheap, you know, it's around $1,300 for that to be attached to or for the unit itself to be attached. So
But it is it is better than the plug-in units that are also an option
The plug-in units run around $300 and it's very simple. You get two in a set. You get two in a set with your purchase
You plug one into an electrical outlet that's associated with the right side of your electrical panel and the other one into an outlet associated with the left side of the electrical panel. So it does create
Whole home protection. It states it's it protects up to about three thousand square feet
And it does work to reduce the the dirty electricity
Does reduce both of them both a hardware unit and the plug-ins reduce
Surges you're reducing the dirty electricity can save money because when you're reducing those surges that are put out by your electrical
the power
That can reduce
You know the dirty the dirty electricity and save money
But the difference is
That these things are all geared towards your electricity that's coming from the power lines
You know hooked up to your house. So anything in your home that runs on electricity. So anything you have plugged in
um
Those are going to be protected with either the hardware unit or these plug-ins
Um, if you want the best then get the hardware unit if that's not in the budget
That's certainly the
Plug-ins would be a great option
The wearables are not protecting um the electricity that's coming into the house. It's just protecting your body
It's changing the frequency
Um to protect your body. So a heatron sticker that's on your cell phone
Um, I would still do that because that's obviously not plugged in
Um, the harmonizer bracelet obviously, you know, your body isn't plugged in
Um, so those things I still would use um if you have a laptop that you use and you're not always plugging it in
Um, I would use a sticker for your laptop as well
So just different options different ways to help you really just individual as to how much you want to spend
But certainly some of the
Things that we have close to us all the time like your cell phone and your laptop good to protect
Yourself with the heatron stickers and um, and then certainly the home if you're
You know at home 24-7
You might want to invest in either one depending on your budget um of those other units
So it can be confusing
But certainly protecting your body is in your best interest other things that are are
Effective as well as feeling feeling the home with plants. So
Especially the room with the Wi-Fi router plants help absorb some of that radiation
I'm going outside and grounding so putting your feet on the earth
So dispersing those positive ions back into the earth. So you're grounded
Those are all helpful
And you know are are pretty
Minimal in cost so just some plants and if you can move things
Out of the bedroom. So if it's possible to move the modem out of the bedroom um
The rife in the laptop. So the rife is actually grounding you
So the photons that are admitted from the rife are actually grounding
So you're not getting EMFs from the rife bulb itself
But the laptop you potentially are getting some so again if you're
You have a sticker on that or you certainly can disconnect the laptop from the rife machine put it in a different room
So you're not sleeping with it in your room
Um, that can be helpful as well, but you're getting grounding
uh frequencies from the rife machine
All right
Next question is there a human version of the dog dewormer
So really that would be something to address parasites and there are a number of products that can address
Parasites um
Just to kind of list a few we have proverma fugue which is a popular one
All just you know different herbs and things to help address
Parasites. There's GI microbex
We also have
Paraclear
Artimicinin is something that can be used as well. So
I would um if you just go on our web store and you type in parasite and
Search bar and you'll get a number of these products coming up
And so then it would just be kind of looking at them and determining what might uh
What you think would be best for you
But that would be kind of the version of human form of the fenn bend is all
All right, just how dangerous is the pet scan and the CT scan
Isn't there something I am supposed to take before and after that to detox? So
pet scans and CT scan so you are being exposed to radiation
Just in kind of different forms depending on the scan, but certainly um
You know to just kind of go back to all of these conversations
We have about conventional care and determining whether or not to do a scan. So if the scan results
Would sway you one way or the other as far as the care that you are receiving then certainly get one of these
scans which one well what is your doctor recommending
um
Have you had any of these either of these scans before so typically if you if you've had a pet scan in the past
You would want to follow up with another pet scan if you're trying to track to see how things are going
Um or if you've had a CT scan then that would be what you want to do to compare
So we want to compare apples to apples different technologies and so some you know I am not totally brushed up on
you know the the details of
Which scan is better for which type of cancer whether it's a soft tissue or a hard tissue so you'll have to look that one up
um
But
How dangerous are they well? I I don't know they both
Have risk they both are exposing you to radiation. So I guess in the decision-making process
You know if you are have decided you're going to get one of these and you're just trying to decide which one
well then
You just
Do the one that you've had in the past or you would just do the one that the doctor is recommending to get the images that they want
um
And yes, we can do things to help you
Help you get rid of that exposure
So I don't know if one is more dangerous than the other
Bottom line is your book you're getting exposed and so if you're going to do one or the other just you know
I guess like I said pick what your doctor is recommending
or based on um what you've had in the past
We do have the homeopathic dropper for radiation exposure. So I would grab that
For either of these scans and start on that
You know, maybe just start a week before your scan is scheduled and then just go through the entire bottle
The dosage is listed on the bottle. I believe it's um
Three drops two times per day. So I would just continue that and then you know try to do some other detoxing
Whether it's doing some detoxing on
um
The rife machine, you know with your supplements. You know be really careful with diet
You know do some extra foot baths some castor oil packs coffee animals all of those things are going to help
With detox
Okay, the difference in the rife bulbs
Can I use my hammer bulb in place of the spiral or the qx tube bulb?
So yes, you can use your hammer bulb with any of the programs that are
Designed for bulb use no matter the bulb
So hammer bulb can be used even if they're recommending the qx tube or the spiral
The difference between them is well the hammer bulb is designed to be used at night at night
It's in case in that covering protected with the styrofoam
So in case it falls out of the bed in case it you know is rolled over the bulb itself is protected
Also um the light coming from the hammer bulb is more damn
It's more of that purple hue versus the brighter red light of the spiral bulb
um, and i'm not sure what
uh the qx tube bulb i i'm assuming it's more of a red color maybe you can't really see that um
So hammer bulb is designed to be used at night spiral bulb bulb is
Something that you can place, you know, it's more concentrated
So if you're trying to treat you know a dental infection
You can put that bulb on your skin right next to you know your cheek
And so you're getting kind of a concentration in a in a smaller area
However, you could just put the hammer bulb close to your cheek
And then the qx tube bulb is something that is stronger
So sometimes patients invest in the qx tube bulb so they can use it during the day
You know, if you're working from your home office you can have the qx tube bulb set up
You know next to or within a couple feet of you and it's stronger
So the frequencies are filling more space in the room so you don't have to have the bulb as close to you
So just different different options and one is not necessarily better than the other
But you can use the hammer bulb that you have
Anytime there's a reference to any of these bulbs
Good question
All right at times the skin on my breast tumor is pinker than others. So that is pretty common
Typically when something the tissue is pinking up it could be
You know related to inflammation
So I guess my question would be
Does it happen
You know, can you track it to after you're doing a
Something specific or after you're eating something specific
Sometimes the foods that we're eating we may not have a digestive reaction to them
But we can have a more systemic reaction to them creating some inflammation
So just kind of watch for that if it's after a certain food
You know, we could do some food sensitivity testing to eliminate some of those inflammatory triggers from foods
Um
Could it be that you know, you just did um, you know, you took a hot shower or you did a sauna or
Is it after a rife program? So those things all are you know, heat is going to increase circulation
It's going to you know, it can make the tissue
seem more pink
Typically we don't recommend heat over a breast tumor unless you're doing
Um hyperthermia so far infrared heat over a breast tumor
but
a lot of times
That
Pink tissue is just due to inflammation so you could up your natural anti-inflammatories if you're taking anything with curcumin with ginger
Boswellia, so those are things that are natural anti-inflammatories
So you can increase some of those or you know, like I said, just kind of pay attention to the signs and symptoms of things that
um, you know, if it's food-related, activity-related, those things can play a role
Um, was that it?
Did we get through them all?
I guess so
I had a couple blank ones here in case some last uh minute questions came in. Let's see from the chat
Um, I wanted to run a headache program, but it looked like it used a bulb all other than the hammer bulb
I was afraid to run the program on the hammer bulb
But the hammer bulb work on a headache program and on the their programs
That mentioned other devices. Yes. So yeah, you can use the hammer bulb
For headache programs and you can use the hammer bulb for any
uh program no matter what bulb they are talking about um the hammer bulb can be used
um
So yes
All right
Oh yes, is there a paint that protects against EMFs? Not then I know of I don't know off the top of my head
They're very well could be
Coming out with more EMF protective products. I know that there's clothing that has EMF protection
Um, I'm not sure about paint. Sorry, you might have to just do a google search on that um
Okay, there is a large fish tank plugged in on the wall
opposite of where Bob sleeps someone said for him to have the wall painted with an EMF blocker
Interesting his head is very close to the wall where the fish tank is
Yeah, you could um, yeah, you could try to see if there is an EMF blocking paint
Um, we do have um
Faraday
Fabric
So Faraday fabric so we we have Faraday cases for your phone and it is a fabric that has
Silver woven into it so it is an EMF blocker
So if you can't find a paint possibly you could find a Faraday
Fabric that you could just kind of hang up
Um on the wall where his headboard is to kind of block that from the opposite wall
So that would be an option, but certainly in our might
Okay, so there might be a paint
That would be really really interesting um, so yeah you can try those things um Faraday
I believe it is spelled F-A-R-A-D-A-Y
Faraday
And then could be wrong
Spelling is not always my strongest uh characteristic
But I think that's how you spell it
And it's close enough to where if you put that in the search bar, I'm sure sure it would come up um
But yeah, you can try that
All right any other questions for me
I don't see any other chat questions
coming in um
that
Took us through the
Zoom submission questions and then I did take some questions that I personally got in my email and put them on here
Just so those could be addressed as well
Okay, I've never had a pet scan, but my oncologist says it's imperative to see where all of this
Recurrence is located as it would influence the treatment I need
Wouldn't you and Dr. Conner's want to know as well if I don't do surgery or chemo well certainly certainly um
You know, and it really is an individual
choice, you know
With what we're doing here we're using the right for using supplements. We're using nutrition. We're using genetics
So that is really our lane and certainly if there's a recurrence, you know
We are we want to know we want to do everything that we can to help you
within our lane
And and so whether or not you get a pet scan
Is is really an individual choice because there is risk involved and then also
We can't you know, we can't recommend it because it is going down that conventional path and we do have to
Stay in our lane and create that that boundary and uh and how you know, it's kind of like
You know the the ethics behind it, you know
Yes, there's risk, you know, it's not in our lane
Um, but who are we to say that you should or should not get a conventional scan?
It really is a personal decision. You have to do what's best for you
And yes, of course we want to know because we want to support you with everything that we can
With everything with the right machine everything with diet everything with
You know your supplements with genetics and so those are the things that we can revisit and we do that with the subsequent cheek swabs
Um, so sending those in and I know you just did a a recent one so you know we
We can do this monthly, you know, we can tweak the protocol. We can recheck things but we have to
Stay in our lane and so as far as getting a pet scan to determine
Every place battery currencies or everything, you know, that's potentially lighting up
That is not necessarily information that we need to know to do what we do
But it would be information that an oncologist needs to know and order for them
To give you direction on what they want you to do. So if
chemo and radiation are something that you are considering then certainly
Move forward with the doctor is suggesting and see what the results are based on those results
Then you can make your decision
Maybe the results are going to be good not what they expected and then you have more peace of mind knowing that okay
I'm staying the course, you know with what what we're doing here
um
But as far as us recommending it, you know, we we can't say one way or the other
I thought with a protocol
I've done in the last year that I wouldn't be able to grow another tumor. So that
That you know, we cannot predict that we never made any claims that this is going to
Get rid of everyone's cancer. It's just not true. There's no
Single thing that is going to eradicate a body from cancer
um
We just cannot predict that we don't know so
The right is a tool just like everything else diet is a tool supplements our tool genetics our tool
So we're doing the best that we can with the tools that we have
You know with the right machine. It's our number one tool that we use to help but there is no guarantee
that it is going to get rid of
Of um
Everyone's cancer. There's no guarantee that it is going to prevent cancer coming back
But it is a tool that can be helpful and you know, there's no way to really determine
Some of these chiming in here. No way to determine, you know
How do you know that the right has not helped maybe
Something would have popped up sooner. Maybe it is preventing
You know metastasis to other parts of the body
um
Maybe it is doing its job and without the right you would have been in a much worse position
There's just no way to know no way to measure you have to
um
You have to make your decisions you have to understand
you know
what
The role is and then make your decisions and just have peace and know that ultimately
All of this is within God's hands and it's
It's uneasy. It's unsettling. It's uncomfortable
But it is a challenge that uh, you know, people with a diagnosis have to face and
So you have to give it to God
Um, would you recommend zeolite
Lano prilite for detox?
Oh, that was a typo
zeolite
clino
Well, I don't know how to say that word, but
zeolite. Yeah, zeolite is a binder that can help with detox
So can bind on to toxins within the gut and help eliminate them hold on to them so your body's not
recirculating those toxins and then to help you
Um, eliminate that through your waste
So zeolite is definitely something that we use in the clinic
Can be a great option if you're looking to add a binder
Okay
Before we started with Connors, we had purchased uh supports healthy cells pathway
one two three um
Anko jumped to division proliferation glucose metabolism clearing cell cycle modulation
We have pancreatic cancer. Are they good to take um just off the cuff
I don't know anything about these products so I'd have to look them up so I can
I can do that and there's certain things that we look for in supplements or supplements that
You know patients come to us already taking or they find an article and they
You know are asking us if it's okay. There's certain things that we are looking for to make sure those products do not have
um
One of them would be methyl groups
methyl groups are the number one thing that can turn off tumour suppressor cells methyl groups attached to different sections of DNA
Turn things off. So if we're supplementing with a with a large amount of methyl groups
We have more of a likelihood
Or a potential that we could be turning off tumour suppressor genes
So we take people off of methyl groups
If they come to us with with supplements that have methyl groups in them
We look at the versions of vitamins. So a lot of times there's you know synthetic versions that aren't so great for you. So
We prefer
Natural, you know supplements that are not synthetic
So cyanocabalamin would be an example of a synthetic version of b12
We do not want you to use that another example would be folic acid. That is the synthetic version of folate
Which is natural so we want to give the body
The natural forms of of vitamins and not the synthetic forms. So we look to see
Those things we also look to see if there's any iron or any
Copper those are things that can encourage blood vessel growth
Fuel sources for cancers. So we don't want patients taking those as well
But I don't know specifically about these products that you listed
I will revisit them
And take a look part of me thinks that you did have these listed on
Your intake form. So we might
Dr. Conner's may have already looked those up and if he didn't say anything, most likely they are okay
But again, I will double check and get back to you. I'll send you an email
checking on those
All right, let's see here
Excuse me
Looking into the emotional roots of cancer diseases
Is good also braiding the storm by Megan Van Zile. Yes, absolutely. Thank you for mentioning that so
Megan Van Zile is a local gal here who we've
worked with
You know as far as you know making connections and Dr. Conner's has done a couple of podcasts with her
We do have her information
Regarding her group support and her book in our binder
We just recently did a binder update which I'm not sure if it's posted on the membership site yet or not
If it's not it will be posted soon, but we do have Megan's information in
The current most recent binder and so she does have a group
A group group sessions. I believe it's all done virtually, but her her focus is
Cancer and the emotions behind it addressing fear you know dealing with past traumas that might have contributed to a diagnosis
So emotions can be a very key component to a cancer diagnosis and oftentimes can be the single thing
That needs to be addressed in order for a person
to
Get into the path of healing to just kind of
Switch thing. Let's get the body into that right chemical soup of healing
Emotions can be a blocker and if they're not addressed can be a reason why somebody is not getting better
So absolutely addressing emotional roots
The her book that you mentioned braving the storm also has a workbook. So those are available on our website so you can look those up
Again, the name of the book is braving the storm
You can buy just the book or you can buy both the book and the workbook as a bundle and save a little bit of money
So those are options to kind of start to address some of the emotional roots of cancer
um and
Everybody should do that and
Address that and certainly for some people it is the key
Missing piece because emotions are often overlooked. So great. Thank you for
mentioning that
All right any other questions
So I have up here just um just the reminder you know log into the patient membership site use this as a resource
Check in with it daily as I mentioned. We're going to be updating the binder to the most recent one
Um, so you'll want to take a look at that Dr. Connors is adding things to this on a weekly basis and still
You really want you guys to use this as your go-to source for everything
Um, and this is the website here the last couple of zoom calls. I had www.
Somebody mentioned that that when she typed that into her search bar that wasn't coming up. So I apologize for that
Um, this is a direct copy paste from the URL so
Bookmark this page so you can access it frequently
All right, everyone. Well that seems to be it on the chat and that was all that came in through um
Through the the forum. So I appreciate you guys
Sending in your questions. Hopefully
My answers have provided a little bit of direction
Um, hopefully they have helped you gain a little bit of clarity
Um, and remember that Dr. Connors is doing the zoom call on Wednesday nights
So you certainly can send in some more questions for him
All right everyone you guys have a wonderful rest of your day and you are very welcome
Thank you guys. I appreciate you guys tuning in and listening
Um, it's it's great that you guys are taking the time to do this
We appreciate that
Have a great day